This is Gage Randall,
and he is going to be a freshman in a couple weeks.
Um, but this past, uh, couple months we've been able
to have just conversations over
what the Lord is doing in his life.
And so I just wanna share a little bit of that.
Um, me
and Gage were talking just about how, uh,
the Lord is showing him that salvation belongs to him.
Nothing we can do can earn that,
but it is all him, uh, his saving power, uh,
and his saving grace in his life that will transform Gage.
And so Gage, based on your profession of faith
and our conversations, it is now my honor to get
to baptize you In the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Good morning church.
Isn't that a beautiful thing to celebrate?